less than three weeks ago juan orlando
hernandez was president of honduras
now he's been arrested by honduran
police following an extradition order by
the united states
security forces were called in on monday
night to surround the wealthy
neighborhood where the former president
of honduras lives
prosecutors in new york have repeatedly
accused the former president of
involvement in drug trafficking and
alleging his political rise was fueled
by drug profits
we've been calling for his arrest since
2015 when we denounced that the former
president was a drug trafficker corrupt
and associated with criminals
hernandez was president of honduras for
eight years u.s prosecutors have accused
him of receiving millions of dollars in
exchange for protecting drug shipments
through the country
the money was reportedly also used to
bribe politicians and help his political
career
the former president has repeatedly
denied the allegations in an audio
recording on tuesday he said he was
willing to voluntarily turn himself in
i'm ready to collaborate and voluntarily
go to the authorities the moment the
supreme court judge is assigned to this
case so that i can face the situation
and defend myself accordingly
hours later a judge appointed by the
supreme court of honduras issued an
order for the president's arrest
it's up to the executive power of the
nation we must wait for an independent
body of the state to make the
corresponding decisions
hernandez left office on january 27th
when the new president xiomara castro
was sworn in
u.s prosecutors claimed that during his
time in office the former honduran
leader helped to facilitate the
trafficking of some 500 000 kilos of
cocaine into the united states calling
this a case of state-sponsored drug
trafficking
manuel rapalo al jazeera